have you ever thought to yourself damn i
have way too many friends i am so
popular i need to start getting rid of
people well in this tutorial i'm going
to teach you how to make everybody you
know and love slowly drift away from you
over the course of your life step number
one talk almost exclusively about
yourself you want to develop a strong
tendency to steer any conversation back
to the topic of yourself you know what
do you have going on what are your
dreams and aspirations what are you
excited about what's something shitty
that happened to you last weekend if you
really want to make talking to you an
agonizing experience then you really
want to monologue about yourself as much
as possible and don't ask questions
about the other person be the one who
answers questions you don't ask
questions do not under any circumstances
give people the impression that you are
interested in them or what they have
going on whatsoever
how's it going man
hey hey um
you know i've
been better um
my my grandpa just died actually grandpa
yeah yeah you're really close and just
like the first death in the family so it
kind of hit me hard yeah damn man yeah
my grandpa is super healthy we're really
happy about that and um yeah he's 78 he
just like ran a marathon it's like
really really cool to see
um
yeah like man grandpa's are so awesome
sometimes listen um can we borrow your
truck on friday tip number two talk
about other people now obviously you
can't talk about yourself the whole time
you might want to sprinkle in a little
bit of detraction while you're at it
talk about mutual friends or
acquaintances in the most negative light
possible voice your dissatisfaction and
your disapproval of their behaviors
their life choices their outfits you
want to generally give people the
impression that you're not someone who
roots for people and want to see them do
well you really want to be known as
someone who is judgmental critical and
generally disapproving of the world
around you and all the people in it
[Music]
jared's a good guy
you know we all like jared but he keeps
on bringing up his dead grandpa like all
the time and it's super depressing
really brings down the vibe tip number
three be useless never extend your hand
to help another person be incredibly
stingy with your efforts to contribute
to the world around you in any
significant way look to weasel out of
work and responsibilities as often as
possible you know let other people do
the heavy lifting say you have a talent
for playing the piano and it's
somebody's birthday and you're at a
party and they say joey you know how to
play the piano can you play happy
birthday for us that would be incredible
that would be so that would be so
amazing
say no don't be generous with your gifts
don't shed positivity to other people
you're not a monkey this isn't the
circus always keep your gifts and
talents to yourself tip number four be a
pessimist one of the most important
traits you can have if you want to be
somebody who is tremendously unlikable
is pessimism you want to suck the life
out of the room if you're part of a
sports team somebody scores a nice goal
and they're in the dressing room
afterwards talking about oh what a
beautiful snipe that was dangle snipe
sully boys you want to be the person who
says
yeah that wasn't that nice like you
could have gone top corner somebody
shows you a piece of art they've been
working on don't congratulate them if
it's good explain how it can be better
always be acutely aware of the fact that
things could be better complain complain
complain holy it's so stupid people
are the worst drivers man i was stuck in
traffic for 45 minutes today it was
brutal excuse me why is my coffee cold
oh my back hurts man i just want to go
home always find something to complain
about call yourself a realist but in
reality you're a pessimist tip number
five be close-minded assume that
whatever information that you have in
the present moment is the gold standard
it's better than whatever anyone else
has been told so when someone shares
their perspective on life with you
always have a cognitive bias against it
it's not what you think so it's probably
wrong assume that because you read it in
a book or watched it on the news that it
must be true never create a space for
dialogue don't talk about the nuances of
a situation close yourself off to that
negative influence most people are sheep
anyways don't let people influence you
psychologically lock yourself into
whatever belief that you have and guard
it with your life tip number six develop
a large ego maintain a constant facade
that you are blameless and perfect never
look at your situation objectively be
blissfully unaware of your flaws and if
you do find some flaws hide them at all
costs you can't let people know that
you're human and just like them you're
perfect you're a god a great way to make
people feel like they just can't get
close to you is to never show any kind
of weakness or vulnerability this will
help you not be relatable whatsoever
always build yourself up and talk very
highly about yourself and be snappy and
defensive when anybody calls your
perfection into question and that leads
very well into tip number eight which is
don't take criticism just as important
as maintaining the perfection of your
character is maintaining the perfection
of your work if you made something it's
the gold standard if people criticize it
they're wrong no matter how valid or
constructive criticism is if it's
directed at you they're wrong after all
you're the one who criticizes
man i am so excited about better ideas
we have the youtube channel now right
but i want to expand into like bigger
and better things the first thing i'm
thinking of kind of a no-brainer
honestly small business loans so if you
need cash you're a struggling company
struggling business i would love to just
hand you cash obviously we take a little
bit of interest that's the whole point
of the business but uh so i just whipped
up a billboard in photoshop you know
you're gonna be driving along the
streets of la new york you're gonna see
these banners um i personally think it's
a super strong design and i just want to
establish trust
so i would love to hear your thoughts i
think it's pretty strong yeah honestly
before i show it to you just know don't
hold anything back be as raw and honest
as possible i love feedback so just you
know be honest i can take it okay all
right i'll be totally honest okay here
we go
hmm
pretty good right
yeah i mean i think i think you could
probably just use a little bit of work
what do you mean
like
for example the the big bracket not a
scam whatsoever and you're like trying
to get gain their trust yeah yeah
absolutely yeah we want all the trust we
can get honestly i think
you could probably lose all of it
especially the not a scam whatsoever um
from a just from a design perspective
like i think
is probably not
not trustworthy at all what do you mean
it's not trustworthy i think
if anyone saw this
they would for sure think it's a scam
like in what way though like i i put
specifically like i i see where you're
coming from but not really because i put
specifically not a scam whatsoever so
people should look at that and say like
okay good thank god right yeah right
yeah no i think
i wouldn't think it's a scammer right
and i'd hope it isn't a scam until i saw
that i would think yeah this is for sure
a scam
well you dude
yeah i mean that's just your opinion
yeah dude like i feel like i put a lot
of effort into this and like i know what
i'm doing with photoshop as a youtuber i
do this for a living um and i just know
what people want to click on what people
want to engage with and i just feel like
this is a really trustworthy banner yeah
yeah um yeah so thanks for your input
really appreciate it yeah thanks a lot
tip number nine be flaky you literally
said like yeah for sure count me in
i'll be there yeah well
you know like i don't know it's been
like tough man like my
my sister's like cousin's dog
passed away like a couple days ago it's
been really tough on the family and i've
been starting
yeah don't be somebody that people can
rely upon you always want to keep people
guessing as to whether or not you're
gonna show up to any particular thing
and i think a great way to do that is to
develop a track record of saying yes to
things but then slinking out of it at
the last moment you're the guy who
always has something that just came up
last second oh something just came up
i'm super sorry i would have loved to
have been there ah i know i said yes but
i'm just so swamped with work i really
wish i could have came out i guarantee
you that if you keep behaving like this
after a long period of time people will
eventually call you less and less until
they don't call you at all that's
perfect
i guess i'll just let you go okay
all right yeah man sorry that sucks but
yeah whoops tip number 10 never assume
initiative always wait around for other
people to come up with plans and things
to invite you to never have your own
ideas never have your own things going
on and never invite people to those
things because there are no things if
you couple this with the previous tip
then when people eventually do invite
you to something you're going to find an
excuse to slink out of it anyways and
over the course of a long period of time
people just generally get the impression
that you don't want to spend time with
them and they will move on to other
people so if you are generally tired of
having a thriving social life and you
want everybody to just leave you alone
and slowly drift away for the rest of
your life then i hope this advice will
help you do just that
kind of a weird video today not gonna
lie i do want to take this opportunity
to give a big shout out to cuts for
sponsoring this video i'm currently
wearing a cuts shirt right now and if
you've watched the past like
10 better ideas videos basically i'm
rocking cuts clothing in basically every
single shot their stuff fits so well it
looks so good and they're hooking you
guys up with 15 off your order when you
use my link in the description below or
use the coupon code joey at checkout and
right now at the time of posting this
video i believe they have a site-wide
sale of 25 off so every single product
on their site is 25 off for the next six
days or so six seven days so now is the
best time to pick up some sick new swag
i don't think people have said swag for
like seven years but yeah if you just
want fresh clothing that looks good and
fits well then go ahead and pick up a
cut shirt and i can pretty much
guarantee you it'll be your favorite
shirt and if you liked this video make
sure that you actually hit the like
button because when you hit the like
button the algorithm shoves my bald head
into other people's home pages helping
them out which also helps me out so it's
a huge win for everybody involved and if
you're lurking here and this is the
thousandth time you've seen my face
consider subscribing and subscribing to
the second channel where a lot of new
content will be posted this september uh
there's stuff there too that you can
check out it's pretty it's pretty funny
stuff it's good stuff other than that
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you in the next video do you get a
new watch yeah i just got it it's like
super expensive super fancy i thought
i'd treat myself i you've been buying a
couple things how'd you afford it yeah
well like i figured i'm starting to make
a bit more money so like i figured i'd
you know spend a bit more money too just
sort of compensate and just even it out
yeah i was also meaning to ask you i'm
like having a fun thing this weekend i
won't get into too many details but i
need just like a little bit of extra
cash i did like just
i like just gave you money like yeah the
other day kind of like similar similar
level like last week
yeah i feel i like i can i can spot you
but i think that you should really start
budgeting and saving it's a pretty
normal practice that people have well
what's the point of like i got a nice
job and i make more money now like
what's the point i'm not spending do i
just like to let the money sit there
like that's such a stupid idea